qui gueulent baffie
pourquoi il a bougé ou pas bien alors
lentilles pas vous connaissez le
portrait chinois le portrait chinois ces
sites étaient une fleur jeu sera un lieu
aux autistes mettons alors aussi
portraits chinois c'est juste l'inversé
si vous étiez une rupture par exemple
une rupture de rythme malte le rythme
voilà une injure or la vache
ah oui c'est ça non mais tu m'énerves
ces cantons une injure sur relance à
quelqu'un ou si elle est choquée la pire
agir pour réduire à quelques violents
nadine de rothschild non non je ne pense
salissage tu m'énerves sa cuisse sur
tout mais qui fout la violence de korité
oui mais bon mais je peux parler on va
se faire censurer tu es malade bons mets
ta gueule euh pardon si utile à des jeux
les gens me saluent taille des crottes
merde vous dire [ __ ] voir à 91 pour
voir dans mes jeux plus longue
non non merci il ya des choses que je
peux dire quand on voit dans le métier 1
si vous étiez une maladie alors une
maladie qui serait pas grave mais qui
pourrait par exemple donner de la fièvre
parce que je sais pas moi j'ai des
souvenirs d'enfant donc jamais
j'avais de la fièvre c'est dans mon lit
pis je sais pas c'était un état que qui
était assez agréable jambon coquillonne
quand on était malade
non mais non mais juste que ça tournait
un peu j'avais comme un comme inverti ça
donnait comme un vertige comme un truc
un peu coco ne l'a et ce n'était pas
désagréable vanille qui donne de la fia
n'est pas grave
ouais si vous étiez une guerre or ben
une guerre de mots mal an pour moi
j'aimais bien ça alors une légale que
faut regarder en tout temps ouais mais
enfin quand on imite les bruits et tous
âges avaient bien inférieur à 50
milliards les arts tous avec un vis à
vis la cour menti ce jeu vous étiez une
arme l'humour un supplice les amours des
gens au cassis les chatouilles déjà tous
les châteaux si vous étiez un poison le
sucre no way un dictateur un dictateur
aura je vais pas être original sûrement
d'autres l'ont dit mais enfin j'en vois
qu'un c c'est charlie chaplin du ray
dont personne ne veut d'une infirmité
timidité ouais ça va laurie là ça va je
suis bien un assassin j'ai été un
assassin
ah oui mais plusieurs fois non dans des
rêves mais parfois c'est très curieuse
j'aurais dû en parler un jour un psy je
dois en parler o minutes
ben j'ai souvent été un assassin qui
n'étaient pas pris je savais qu'il
savait que quelqu'un avait tué mais il
savait pas encore que c'était moi je
courais enfin ça doit être un truc de
culpabilité vient de sortir là une
torture chatouille l'humiliation
gratuit
donc on est parti dans le très hard si
vous étiez une mort de rire
voilà michel jonasz à l'avis de l'isda
le pierre grimblat avec benoît magimel
saga lens l1 jeanne moreau marion
cotillard
laquelle a abouti voilà alors